i've been using homepod and echo devices
for years now and today
i'll tell you who should buy the new
homepod mini and who will be happier
with an
echo either the new round ones or the
super steel of a deal
third generation echo dot which you can
get right now for just 18.99
using the link down below there are
great benefits of each platform and
device
but for those of you who want a quick
answer i'll link my personal suggestion
best device in the description as well i
have to say that after digging into this
there are some massive differences that
you won't find looking at the product
pages
you definitely don't want to make a
mistake buying the wrong one
and if you watch this whole video i will
guarantee that you'll be able to make
the right choice for you
before this comparison let's quickly go
over the homepod mini announcement
i'm glad that the mini isn't just a
shrunken down homepod
but it's redesigned with a mostly round
shape personally i think it looks great
and i'm glad that we still have that led
touch surface
with volume controls up top we have the
same mesh which looks and feels really
nice
but if you have kids around i would
suggest getting the black since the
white gets really dirty easily
and it's really tough to clean it's hard
to gauge the size of the mini when you
see it on camera
here you can see how much smaller it
truly is
the mini is slightly less than half the
height and about 50 smaller in diameter
so the size difference is significant
what's even more crazy is when you
compare the weight with the homepod
being more than seven times heavier
five and a half pounds instead of 0.76
which means that this thing is really
lightweight and that 19
echo dot weighs in at around the same
amount while being half the height of
the mini apple said they focused on
four things with the homepod mini
amazing sound intelligent assistance
smart home support and privacy and
security starting with the speakers
or should i say speaker since there's
only a single driver that fires through
these little slots
for 360 degree sound apple doesn't list
the size of the speaker but based on the
image i would have to say it's about two
inches
we also have two radiators on the sides
which will really improve the bass
response
which is great since the speaker is
small and apple doesn't market it
as a high excursion like it does with
the regular home pod
even though the homepod space wasn't
loud it did go really low for a smart
speaker so i hope that the mini could
get close to that with those radiators
unfortunately the mini doesn't have any
dedicated tweeters
which make for clean crisp high
frequencies where the original has
7 dedicated tweeters apple made
computational audio a big deal with
tuning that happens in real time
180 times a second using that s5
chip which was the flagship apple watch
chip last year
and is really powerful for a 99 device
this will be a big deal when i get into
the comparison to the echoes in just a
bit
the other difference is you can't use
the mini with your apple tv
which probably speaks to their maximum
loudness but enough with the homepod
comparisons we'll do a detailed
dedicated video once it's out
so subscribe if you guys want to see
that let's move on to the convenience
features
the first is auto stereo pairing if you
have two of them in one room
thanks to the u1 chip which makes home
pods easy setup
now even easier thanks to that same chip
in the coming months if you have an
iphone 11 or newer
you can hand off music by bringing your
phone near the homepod mini
which is also really cool thankfully
apple is finally adding pandora and
amazon music support to the homepod
but unfortunately there's no word about
their biggest competitor
spotify the coolest new feature has to
be intercom
and right away i thought it was just a
copy of echo's drop-in
but it goes a lot further i use drop-in
all the time to talk
to my kids who might be playing in the
basement or maybe they're in their rooms
and amazon recently added the ability to
drop in on all echoes as well
what it can't do though is intercom into
airpods
which can be super convenient if your
kids are listening to music
while you're trying to call them or talk
to them the other part is the great
integration with carplay
not only to easily and safely intercom
while on the road
and have those audio messages show up on
apple devices but to intelligently have
directions show up
if you ask siri for info about a
specific place
this is where the homepod really stands
out the deep integration with other
apple devices
and this is honestly making it tempting
to replace my
echoes with these new homepod minis yes
you can do some of these things on the
echoes but
each person needs to have alexa apps
installed and working properly on their
devices
and manually set up profiles which is a
much bigger pain with the echoes
i'm a huge techie and i still have
issues with the alexa app
and finding the certain things that i
need and adjusting them
where the ease of setup and simplicity
of just using siri that's already built
into your phone
is just incredibly easy the other major
difference is
privacy both the echoes and homepods can
support multiple users but the homepod
is more seamless
and most things are done on the device
instead of in the cloud
in anything that is being sent up is
encrypted with those multiple profiles
if the person
isn't in the home other people won't be
able to use their profile
privacy could be a concern with any
device but i definitely trust apple
way more than amazon and that's sadly
where the benefits end
and here's a ton of reasons why i
personally switch to echoes
from home pods first off alexa is way
more capable not only does it support
over 60
000 devices but there are over 100
000 skills which are kind of like apps
for your echo
from third parties because of this
echoes could do way more and smart
device companies can easily add voice
features to the echo
along with that if you're somebody that
wants to easily shop with your voice
you definitely want to get an echo for
that i couldn't find a figure for how
many homekit devices are out there
but from my research i would say that
it's less than 10
of the ones that are compatible with
echoes so if you're looking to create a
smart home
almost every smart device out there
works with the echo
now along with much wider device support
third-party software integration is also
way better one of the biggest
differences for me is
spotify support both replacing amazon
music using my voice
and also using spotify connect which is
super handy
oh and by the way apple music also works
perfectly on
echoes like it does on the homepod i can
control music
from my spotify app on my phone on my
watch on my tv
or on any web browser even over lte no
matter where i'm at
and i can play music to groups of echoes
or even my whole house
and it won't disrupt whatever else i'm
listening to or watching or doing
on my phone or anywhere else really with
the homepod you could do similar things
if you're on the same wi-fi and you're
using apple music
but if you want to use spotify you have
to use airplay which will directly cast
your audio from your phone to the
homepod it's basically like bluetooth
but a little bit better since it uses
your wifi
but that also means that you need wi-fi
for it to work if you want to listen to
something else or your connection cuts
out
airplay will stop and in general it's
way less reliable than using spotify
connect
which streams audio from the cloud like
the homepods do with apple music
so if you're a user of spotify the
experience is
drastically better on echo devices and
since i mentioned bluetooth
homepods don't allow you to use it if
you want to stream to the homepod your
app
better support airplay and if your
friend comes over with an android device
he is out of luck not only can echoes
work as a bluetooth speaker so anybody
can connect to it directly
and they can stream to it and they'll
still work if your network is down
but they can also connect to other
bluetooth devices and directly stream to
them
i have a massive fluent speaker that is
insanely
loud which supports bluetooth so with
just my voice i can connect to it and i
can use alexa to stream
and get incredible sound and if you have
speakers that don't support bluetooth
all echoes have three and a half
millimeter outputs
so you can turn your dumb speaker into a
smart one none of this is possible
on the homepod it works best with apple
apps from apple
devices and with music that can only
play on it
and only if your wi-fi is working the
whole pod might be
apple's most locked down device and
anything that connects to it has to be
approved and controlled by apple
which means that there could be a lot
less home kit devices that are out there
and a lot of those are gonna be more
expensive as well now let's circle back
and finish up with audio quality when
listening to music which is probably
what most people spend
most of their time doing with their
smart speakers i'm almost certain that
the mini will sound better than the echo
dots
which share the same 1.6 inch speaker
but that's to be expected at 50 dollars
for the new one
and a crazy 19 right now for the third
gen
these don't sound fantastic but they're
still very usable at medium volumes
and if you buy it for that price which
by the way there's links in the video
description
i don't think anybody's gonna complain
my question is
how it will compare to the new standard
echo that comes in at the same
99 this thing is slightly larger but
features
three speakers instead of one a three
inch woofer and two tweeters that are
about 20 millimeter
my question is how it will compare to
the new standard echo
that comes in at the same 99
this thing is slightly larger but it
features three speakers instead of one
a three inch woofer and two 20
millimeter tweeters
amazon is so confident in its audio
quality that they even included a line
in
option to connect music players to the
speaker if you guys want to see
how they compare click that subscribe
button below but if i had to guess
i would have to give it to the echo
because of its three dedicated drivers
and i'm almost certain that it will play
louder now if you're somebody that wants
the features of alexa but you want
amazing sound you can get the echo
studio for fifty dollars more than the
homepod mini
and this one has five speakers with
dedicated drivers for the highs
the mids and the low base overall i have
to say that i am tempted by the few
standout features of the homepod mini
i love how they look and how easy they
are to use and the new
integrations with other apple devices
are great but they lack
so many features both software and
hardware
that unless you have a very limited use
case and you're very deep
into the apple ecosystem and not using
anything else
honestly it's really hard to recommend
them i'll leave my recommended devices
and the best sales on echoes down below
in the video description
thank you guys for watching let me know
your opinions on which one
you should buy and which system is
better click that circle above to
subscribe since we will be doing some
real world comparisons when the mini
comes out
this is max and i'll see you in the next
[Music]
video
[Music]
you